good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan sensor every so often the
West Coast Tech Giants are hauled over
to the east coast of the United States
for a ritual humiliation at the hands of
the US Senate they land a few punches
they get punched a few times a few
headlines get generated and you end up
with some very powerful people looking
pretty uncomfortable but nothing
normally really changes when it comes to
an issue as serious as child abuse it
surely has to yesterday the head honchos
of Tech Giants meta Tik Tok Snapchat X
appeared in Congress to face questions
on the serious harm their products are
causing to Children some of the
exchanges were toe curling none more so
than the moment Mark Zuckerberg who runs
meta which is Facebook and Instagram
attempted to explain why some content
flagged his child abuse on Instagram
somehow remains available to
view this material wasn't just living on
the dark corners of Instagram Instagram
was helping pedophiles find it by
promoting graphic hashtags
including # ped and # Preen
sex to potential
buyers Instagram also displayed the
following warning
screen to individuals who were searching
for child abuse
material the these results may contain
images of child sexual abuse and then
you gave users two
choices get
resources or see results
anyway Mr Zuckerberg what the hell were
you
thinking all right Senator um the the
the basic science behind that is that
when people are searching for something
that is problematic it's often helpful
to rather than just blocking it to help
direct them towards something that um
that could be helpful for getting them
to get help in what I understand get
resources in what San universe is there
a link for see results anyway well
because we might be
wrong well yeah you might be but really
that's the excuse surely if there is any
risk whatsoever that images of child
abuse are being shared they must be
instantly removed How can any same
person argue otherwise Senator lindsy
Graham was loudly cheered by watching
parents when you said this Mr Zuckerberg
you and the companies before us I know
you don't mean it to be so but you have
blood on your hands you have a
product you have a
product that's killing people well he
has a product that's incredibly popular
and it's made him incredibly Rich a lot
of people use Facebook very safely and
there's no problem with that it's one of
the most successful companies in history
but the people that would were cheering
there were parents whose children had
been victims of horrific exploitation on
those platforms or whose children had
taken their lights well Mark Zuckerberg
made this
apology would you like now to apologize
to the victims who have been harmed by
your prod show them the pictures would
you like to apologize for what you've
done to these good people I'm sure
everything of you have all gone through
terrible no one should have to go
through the things that your families
have have suffered and this is why we
invest so much and are going to continue
doing industry-leading efforts to uh to
make sure that no one has to go through
the types of things that your families
have had to Suffer Well despite his
rather unfortunate tendency to look and
sound like an AI generated lawyer I do
believe Mark Zuckerberg wants his
products to be a force for good in the
world and at least he had the decency to
turn around and apologize to those
parents he wasn't by any means the only
Tech Giant boss there they were all
there but he was the one that did that
and credit to him for doing so this is
the way the modern world communicates
it's where we're entertained and
educated social media it's integral to
our lives it's not going to go anywhere
it's going to get bigger and bigger
that's exactly why we need to trust that
the people in charge of it know what
they're doing and do it properly one
thing they're very good at is keeping us
safe from content they find is stayful
we might remember the scandal of the
hunter Biden laptop which disappeared
from your Faceook Facebook news feed
disappeared from Twitter it was called
then deliberately censored by big tech
and as a result Joe Biden won the
election and we'll never know whether
the Scandal had it been properly allowed
to permeate through social media because
it was all true might have tipped the
balance towards Donald Trump to serve a
second
term and yet ironically Facebook along
with others moved quickly to ban Trump
himself from their platforms for three
years well currently uh the peers Morgan
uncensor Facebook page appears to have
been Shadow band to this is a regular
occurrence where if they don't really
like the look of some content they just
downplay it for the audience so that
people don't see it I don't think that's
right I think that's a form of
censorship too meta makes a hundred
billion dollar a year profit it's time
to invest less of it in sanitizing
opinions and more on keeping children
safe and that applies to all those other
platforms too
well to discuss that and more I'm joined
by Seth Dyan CEO of the satirical news
site Babylon B the computer scientist
and author of arguments for deleting
your social media accounts right now
Jaren lania and the entrepreneur and
host of Round Table Mario noral well
welcome to it's a pretty star studied uh
Tech pack this actually let me start
with you Seth um CEO of Babylon B hugely
successful um digital platform when you
watched all these guys like Zuckerberg
yesterday squirming away and being held
to account by people who've you know
suffered serious harm lost their
children in some cases what did you feel
about
that well you know I don't take pleasure
in them uh suffering through a moment
like that I mean obviously I don't think
that they feel good about the fact that
there are kids who have committed
suicide or have dealt with bullying and
harassment or who have had who have had
exploitative material of them shared
online I don't think that they feel good
about that but they they do bear some
responsibility for it in the sense that
their platforms are doing a very poor
job of policing themselves and taking
these things down they care a lot more
about jokes that they don't like
apparently than they do about content
like this because they catch that stuff
and take it down right away and
sometimes these uh sometimes this
content this really offensive or
unlawful content stays up for an
extended period of time and it's
difficult for them to get it down so
they do have some explaining to do U but
I don't feel good about seeing them red
over the coals for it I'd like to see
some actual Solutions rather than just
these conversations where we they show
up and we throw some punches at them and
they leave a little bruised and battered
but don't do anything about it yeah I
mean Mario I I follow your stuff on X
and you're a Relentless uh Tweeter you
tweet a lot of exciting stuff and it you
a lot of it is very interesting um L of
it's pretty full on I would argue as
well probably more for an adult consumer
than I would feel comfortable with a
child uh following some of it because
you know you cover Wars and everything
else do you think there's a line I mean
is there a limit to what should be put
on these
platforms there is but who's to decide
those limits like that hearing was a
circus you got the same people behind so
someone just called me apologized so you
got the same people behind a lot of
these and put Focus mode a lot of the
censorship yeah yeah sorry I just put it
do not disturb so the same people behind
the censorship so censoring information
about Co that they call misinformation
censoring information when it comes to
election interference and what they
consider to be um misinformation again
and now they're using a topic that is
the right thing to sensor illegal
content but suddenly they care and you
got Senators Elizabeth Warren Mark
Warner Amy kobar they were behind a lot
of that censorship over the last few
years but now suddenly they need to
censor certain content legal and social
media companies need to do more I just
find it ridiculous do you self censor I
mean is there a lot of stuff you don't
post because you think actually younger
people shouldn't see
this our audience is not younger people
so if you want to hold me as but how do
you know that a person exactly so it's
difficult for me so my content is out
there how do you prevent young people
from seeing that content obviously
Banning children from getting to social
media companies which some people
propose is a stupid idea you've tried
Banning children from porn websites all
you do is get a disclaimer are you above
the age of 18 yes or no that's it that's
not going to work so the solution in my
opinion is a lot trickier than what
these guys making out to be and you've
got these Senators essentially using
this as an opportunity to show that they
care but the the bigger agenda is not
child exploitation they don't care as
much as they show it they care about
their their specific agendas that
they're trying to sneak in Under the
Umbrella of censoring content like Char
porn which should be censored right let
me bring in jarn Leonard jarn you're a
computer scientist he's done a lot of
research into this kind of thing I've
been struck by that there's been an
epidemic of anxiety about amongst young
people around the world and precisely
the same period of time in in society
when there's been an explosion in social
media and the ready availability of what
I would call dopamine hit material of
all kinds whether it's pornography
whether it's Warfare whatever it is it's
constant and they're sharing it and
they're being exposed to it you know I
get exposed to it and I'm 58 years old
old and I know it has a bit of an effect
on me sometimes you know during the
Israel Hass War it's been really
harrowing to see this stuff just
bombarding my senses so God knows what
it's like for an 18yearold a 19y old um
do you think there's a a link here
between this eruption of anxiety that
young people are suffering and this
constant feed they're getting of of
dangerous or unsettling or illegal
imagery almost all researchers whether
they're coming from the left or the
right have come to the conclusion that
it does do damage and by the way I want
to say I'm kind of more from the left
than you guys and I'm kind of happy we
have an issue where we meet here I think
that's healthy and maybe that's a gift
tech is bringing to us uh in my view the
root problem here is actually just one
law that could be changed that's not
serving anybody and it's called section
230 and what it does is it treats uh
internet hubs as if they were phone
companies instead of Publishers and the
problem with that is something nobody
saw I was around when we started this so
um I I share part of the blame perhaps
but if you remove enough liability from
the internet platforms it means that
their competitors can kind of put out
the same stuff that they put out so the
only business model they have is to gain
what we call Network effect which is a
kind of Monopoly and then to sell uh
influence and routing of information or
basically to sell virality through Al
RMS and then the problem with that is
virality runs on the fight ORF flight
mechanisms of the human brain and it
tends to make everybody a little more
nervous and cranky and uh Vain and uh
you know all those things we see it more
easily in our ideological opponents but
the truth is it affects all of us uh
pretty equally uh so what I'd like to
see is just simply to change that law
and I think what you'll see is the good
side of social media which is very real
have more of a chance and the incentives
for the stupid stuff to be reduced and I
think all of us will be happy and by the
way to my co-panelists I think you'll do
better in business in that world you
might not agree but I think if it
happens you'll discover that so I I
really want to encourage everybody to
look at this win-win scenario which is
just getting rid of one stupid law it's
very rare we have such an easy path yeah
but I actually think my
observation um of the extremities on
social media is that the extreme left
and extreme right can be as bad as each
other with the click baking BAS and the
way they go about it I don't think
there's much difference from what I've
seen Seth let me bring you back on on
another point which is how much should
parents be taking responsibility for
enabling their kids to have the phones
to get access to all this
stuff well I think this is where the
problem starts it starts at home it
starts with how parents raise their kids
and what they put in front of them you
know my comment on this uh when I first
saw the you know hearings happening was
that you know it's certainly these are
dangerous platforms they're they're
dangerous even for adults to be on these
platforms and it's it's okay for us to
have exposure to some dangerous things
because we're adults and we know how to
deal with it but what are you doing as a
parent putting something dangerous like
that into the hands of your own child
and then just setting them free to go
use that device while you you know do
your own thing and don't have to worry
about you parenting your child because
they're entertained on this device for
hours that's having very damaging
effects on kids kids are getting cell
phones in their hands when they're seven
eight n 10 years old they're not
prepared to encounter the content that
they encounter there the algorithms are
designed to suck those kids in and make
them addicted to that to that content uh
has very very damaging effects so
parents that's the first line of defense
is parents there are plenty of apps that
enable parents to control that stuff
parents shouldn't be putting the devices
in their hands in the first place um but
they feel pressured to because all the
other kids have them but that's that's
just parenting 101 Mario what do you
think of
that they're finding ways around it it's
a lot more complex Seth like you know
it's always easy to blame the parent but
there's only so much they could do
there's apps to block certain websites
to block certain apps but there's ways
around around it and and these children
are smarter than their parents in
finding ways around it so I think social
media the first line of defense not the
whole the whole answer agree agree but
what What's Happening Here is that this
hearing is focusing on on the social
media companies censoring the children
which I think there should be some level
of censorship but I think censorship
isn't the solution I think focusing on
the source is the solution I remember
Elon mus was talking about this when no
one was and he was being criticized for
it we did a space about it in the early
days and no one really cared about it
the media barely covered it now suddenly
it's a big deal great finally they're
paying attention after Wall Street
Journal and other Publications did um um
uh did hit not hit pieces I'd say did
the analysis on this but now starting to
talk about the only solution being
social media companies censoring further
more than the censorship that we have
now rather than focusing on the source
itself is I think going to lead to
bigger problems we're just think it's
like everything is solved through
censorship and I think that's dangerous
yeah I think you making a good point
Jaren let's talk about one social Med
platform in particular because it's the
biggest news source now for young people
in the world it's Tik Tok and of course
it originates from China a lot of
concern about what may be going on there
what the Chinese may be up to um a lot
of concern about the effect it's having
on society and on young people in
particular what do you think of Tik
Tok oh my God you know look I'm about to
trash Tik Tok so I want to put in one
positive sentence I actually like a lot
of the stuff on it I like Tik Tok
culture hate me if you on for that so
I'm not anti- youth culture but I mean
my God look at the difference between
the version of Tik Tok in China and the
version externally one is obviously
designed to improve society and when is
designed to harm Society uh because we
don't get access to the data because the
thing's a black box ultimately it's
almost impossible to really really know
what's going on what's intentional
what's sneaky and what what's not um I
have talked to prominent people in
Chinese uh government and Industry
circles who bring up uh their centy of
humiliation the Opium Wars uh and I get
the impression that for some in China
this might be viewed as kind of fair
play of a kind of a reflecting back to
us what was done to them in what was for
them a very recent memory even though
for us it feels pretty obscure I don't
but I can't know you know this is the
thing that's so frustr ating is that um
there is really no way to know for sure
what's going on except we can say that
uniformly people who study it think that
Tik Tok is mostly doing harm yeah it's
of obviously it's a mixed story there's
some good stuff on it but I just think
it's intolerable I think it's a horrible
a horrible horrible thing and something
has to be done about it um I don't like
censorship anymore than my fellow
panelists do but I also think we can
remove the business incentives for the
worst content which is a different issue
and at least that ought to help a lot
well one thing I think that does help is
talking about it uh and I appreciate all
three of you joining me for a really
interesting panel thank you very much
indeed